how everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to let's play psychosis
I've already disturbed because there's
one freaky looking clown on the left and
then there's a terrifying little girl on
the right so I don't know what I'm
getting myself into but he looks
diabolical and I don't like it at all
don't look play why don't we okay
collect all the keys to escape what
sounds familiar
also that music sounds eerily familiar
can I pick that up please can I have
that okay wait what I didn't okay
whatever
there's a flashing light there and it's
not helping me at all anyway I gotta
find the keys and escape the clown and
the little girl
can I go that way yes a candle stuck on
a chair huh there seems to be a strange
hole in the roof
oh well shoddy housing design and all
that let's see what we're getting
ourselves into I wonder when the first
jump scares gonna happen oh boy
I don't like this at all but anyway
Caesar key hears that a key I think I
see a key thank you so I got one one out
of how many I'm not quite sure but I got
one and I'm pretty sure rounding every
single corner I'm gonna find something
to start told me hey look a door can I
help in you
nothing like looping door sounds to get
the atmosphere all settled in nice fire
effects I can see the budget was just
astronomical a news game from the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre there's a big ol
machete why can't I take that with me I
would like that what is that it's a
typewriter that says raccoon on it
there's some barrels there is no key
here and lo Oh balls
okay yeah they need to definitely fix
the sound in this game but the wood whoa
hey what Val cam focused on what the
hell this is besides a body bag with an
umbrella corporation logo on it I have a
feeling there might be some car this son
of [ __ ]
oh good I'm going outside I'm sure that
wandering into a cornfield is a great
idea
reminds me of the level of left for dead
I always liked that one with a farmhouse
I always like the original left for dead
oh my god
okay other than being loud I'm just
assuming that there was nothing the
actually chasing me which was my first
assumption okay alright so I didn't see
anything out there and if there was
something I must have missed it there's
got to be a key out here somewhere then
uh-huh I can't say that this is a good
game but it's definitely got the scare
jump scare element into it and very
creepy atmosphere and that music does
sound exceptionally familiar I think it
might be from like a slender game or
something I'm not sure anyway
can't find anything in this maze of a
cornfield I don't even know if there's
anything to find out here other than
just being startled by the noise is I'm
just trying to check there's a key or
something okay does it look like it okay
back to the house let's go back inside
oh fudge I'm lost which way am I going I
don't get back to the house and I just
wasn't I just at this tree I was wasn't
I and there's more fence just follow the
fence you'll get there eventually I like
this game this game Kirk's me this game
does perk me okay here we go come on
come on keep you together I don't think
there was anything actually out here
this house is strange do not like it
[ __ ] mannequin [ __ ] mannequin
[ __ ] wheelchair [ __ ] body on the
wall [ __ ] man there wasn't even a key
in here unless it was like something in
the fire knob ok carrying on let's go to
another outer part of the house find out
how we're gonna die next because
apparently we've got 10 bajillion ways
to die in this game
what okay nope there's nothing down
there I found one key why do I need so
many damn keys what's the point of
getting keys
those are they like ten doors that I
need to unlock some I never understood
its like slender claustrophobia why do I
need somebody damn Keys just need find
new things for me to find and go on my
merry way
oh I see is like 10 fum two billion
locks on this giant ass door well I mean
how many keys was there to find I can't
sprint and I'm crawling at a snail's
pace
just waiting for things to jump out at
me I thought one key one you can't
possibly expect me to go back out into
the cornfield again look for keys that's
all I should organize dick punching
parties whenever I disagree disagree
with game mechanics I have the power I
have the power to do this I can was
there one hiding like back here or
something maybe map ah and the teddy
bear was nothing right the teddy bear
just a cute little dead look teddy bear
looks familiar by the way I think that's
stolen from another game say doll okay
did you have a key with your intestines
all spilling out onto the wall did you
have a key
nothing then there's got to be a key out
in this cornfield somewhere
somewhere there's gotta be some it's
easy to miss because it's nondescript
my vision is cluttered and I hate my
life I hate my life I'm forced to play
these games that I don't understand
oh well stop being such a baby
markiplier get it out and get it up and
get it on
aha there's a pathway here two more
found it found it jiggly jiggly jiggly
jiggly well what the [ __ ] oh you gotta
be joking
I finally found another door and you
sons of [ __ ] [ __ ] got a ram
[ __ ] repeatedly eyeshadow run I've been
watching too much Spartacus never seen
not the original movie but the like the
Showtime series all of it everything
they talk about is ramming Cox into
something or other it's just not not not
appropriate why is that grass there I
don't know okay alright I'm just kind of
skirting the outskirts looking for
something and there is nothing there's
nothing here there's no thing there's no
thing here nothing on this tree there's
nothing in the middle of the field
there's just nothing it's a whole lot of
nothing absolutely
dick diddly whoa ah there it was the key
the mother [ __ ] key on the tree which
I tried to find before I was spamming my
used button both of them mouse clicking
and the use button before it I couldn't
find it but I'll add our ladder
let's just go tine box says this key
doesn't go to this door hi oh ho
I still don't like that damn looping gah
ah ah okay honey a [ __ ] cloud didn't
even really see it
Oh which way do I go this way
cuz it seems like [ __ ] Jason
god damn it what the hell
James's balls can you give a key Oh same
thing actually gotta kill me just
killing and the torment oh man
ceaseless loose
doors don't sound like that
what is this what ruff that was it
how is it okay man oh man I don't know
you won't know why he did it that way
the team members for that seems like
that could have been programmed into
unity in a day okay if all it was was
jumpscares just so many jump scares just
unbelievable number of jump scares but
either way it's entertainment for you
guys if you guys want to try the game
out for yourself there's not much
content besides the jump scares if you
watch this and you kind of got all of it
so oh okay so yeah hopefully you enjoyed
me screaming like a little girl haven't
had a game where I just do that for a
while so thank you all so much for
watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
don't even try get up don't try talking
to you zombie gone up watches oh you son
of a [ __ ] you betrayed me I trusted you